У 60-річної продавчині Наталі торгівля не кипить:
купівельна спроможність жителів Хмільника впала,
а витрати на оренду і закупівлю товару навпаки зростають.
Обидва її сини виїхали до Польщі на заробітки -
там у них кращі шанси.
У зниженні рівня життя в Україні звинувачує чинного президента.
Може десь на міжнародному рівні ми піднялися,
але в нас у малих містах ми цього не помічаємо.
Дуже шкода, що всі діти, вся молодь, всі виїжджають.
Усі її сподівання тепер - на шоумена Володимира Зеленського.
Саме у ньому вона побачила такого собі "непідкупного Голобородька",
якому готова віддати свій голос у другому турі виборів.
Багато прихильників коміка і серед її постійних покупців,
приміром, 57-річна Лариса.
Дивилася "95 квартал", хлопець талановитий..
Можна сказати, не спорчений ще.
Може, буде якась переміна в нашому житті... Все-таки свіжа кров.
Сам Зеленський до Хмільника під час передвиборчої кампанії не навідувався.
Свою програму для мешканців міста
озвучував з екранів телевізорів у серіалі "Слуга народу".
Саме такому образу й повірили багато мешканців Хмільника.
Що він матінку правду чеше і нікого не боїться.
Він, до речі, всього добився сам.
Те, що він крутився і розкрутився, він своєю головою добився.
Тим часом неприємно вражені результатами першого туру виборів
медичні працівники найстарішого в місті санаторію "Хмільник".
Тут більшість - за чинного президента.
За кілька днів до першого туру Порошенко
уперше завітав до 28-тисячного курортного містечка.
Для працівників санаторію приїзд гаранта став справжньою подією.
Церква - це велике має значення, безвіз, армія.
Зміцнення армії! Мені імпонує те,
що президент набрався сміливості і попросив пробачення
за те, що якби не знаючи тієї обстановки, сказав,
неможливо зразу так війну зупинити.
А чого не виконав за 5 років - мусить встигнути
бодай розпочати до другого туру виборів, вважають тут.
Хотілося би більше бачити боротьби з корупцією,
то так, ну хоча б вже зараз, ну хоча б до другого туру,
хай показово когось посадить, щоб люди  хоча би
хоча б так проголосували за нього в другому турі.
Голоси за обох кандидатів у президенти
у Хмільнику розділилися майже порівну.
Аби здобути перемогу у другому турі виборів,
Порошенку та Зеленському треба тепер змагатися за голоси тих,
які не прийшли на вибори у першому турі...
Багато таких, що не підуть ні за кого. Що хрест поставимо на обох.
Або ж проголосували за інших кандидатів.
Наприклад, за голос продавця Олександра,
який у першому турі підтримав Юлію Тимошенко.
У другому турі яще не вирішив, буду за кого...
визначатися ближче до 21-го числа.
Тоді я вже буду знати.
З одного боку, каже, його обурюють порожні обіцянки політиків,
як-от припинення бойових дій на Донбасі у короткі строки.
З іншого - не розуміє,як шоумен буде вести війну з Росією.
Зрештою акценти можуть розставити ймовірні
передвиборчі дебати на НСК "Олімпійському".
Олександр дуже хотів би їх подивитися,
аби врешті визначитися зі своїм кандидатом.